la maîtresse c'est elle ça allait bien
geneviève cardin est ce qu on a des
questions sur le meilleur jour une
enseignante du primaire qui a tout lâché
pour démarrer ce resto bar il ya un an
l'enseignement elle n'en pouvait plus
sabine lots de moins en moins d'appuis
de plus en plus d'élèves plus en plus
d'élèves en difficulté moins d'appuis de
plusieurs parents c'est après un bernard
qu'elles abandonnent le métier se
faisait pourtant qu'ils en quelle
enseigne et tient une cuisine un petit à
petit des choses on accumule ça devient
lourd un moment donné ça devient
invivable 26 élèves g19 plan
d'intervention j'ai pas plus d'ailleurs
cette année là l'orthopédagogue ne peut
pas avoir plus d'or dans ma classe riche
on respire
mis à part à vouloir tout ça les a aidés
au québec selon plusieurs études un
enseignant sur quatre abandonnent le
métier au cours des sept premières
années
une proportion qui se compare à celui
des travailleurs de la santé des
policiers
pascal desormeaux elle aussi à quitter
le métier
épuisée elle a rejoint sa bonne amie
geneviève et les maintenant serveuse
avant que j'arrive à l'épuisement
aubenas moi je me suis retiré après 17
elle constate que son métier n'est plus
ce qu'il était avec donc des troubles de
comportement des élèves en crise des
tdah des des élèves avec des troubles de
l'autisme
il ya beaucoup de gestion de
comportement des gestions d'élèves en
difficulté de gestion de parents son
micro par an mais les parents ne vont
pas nécessairement ont réprimandé leur
enfin ils ont plus de réprimande ou
liste d'enseignants leur examen ça sort
pour mon enfant professeurs donc ça
c'est lourd
au bout du compte au cours des
prochaines années selon les données du
ministère de l'éducation
ces quelques milliers d'enseignants qui
devrait démissionner rien donc pour
aider les directions d'école qui font
déjà face à une pénurie d'enseignants et
un manque de suppléants
on a une amie qui était en arrêt pl et
au retour progressif et la semaine
passée quatre personnes différentes
remplacé dans sa classe pour la semaine
parce qu'il n'était pas grave de trouver
une personne pour faire les quatre jours
à ce qu'elles ne seraient pas là elle
pleurait une enseignante de première
année elle elle pleurait parce que je
faisais mon petit bout'chou ont besoin
de quelqu'un d'un constat je vais vous
avez mis une 407 classe de l'université
du québec à montréal on retrouve le riz
elle a toujours rêvé de devenir
enseignante
pour elle pas de doute elle veut
toujours faire ce métier les enseignants
quant à change les problèmes des élèves
puis je crois pas et qui devraient être
les seuls dans ce bateau là parce que il
des travaux plusieurs sauces pour
revaloriser le métier
la carte propose entre autres
d'augmenter le nombre de professionnels
comme des orthopédagogues qu'on trouve
dans les classes mais aussi surtout de
bonifier de 8000 dollars le salaire
d'embauché des nouveaux enseignants et
je crois qu est d'autres choses puisque
le sahara parce que les enseignants qui
travaillent qui reste malgré les
consomme que ça fait plus que cinq ans
que sont le respect qu aux saveurs il
reste à cause qui sont passionnés à
costes yade qui aiment leurs élèves à
l'université de montréal à la faculté
des sciences de l'éducation
on compte l'augmentation du salaire des
enseignants est plus que nécessaire
l'enseignant moyens à ma connaissance
préféré avoir plus de soutiens pour
faire son travail d'enseignant que
d'avoir un salaire plus élevé cependant
je persiste à penser que le salaire des
enseignants pourraient être plus élevés
on est capable d'en donner aux médecins
des salaires peu élevés je pense que les
enseignants en mériterait aussi
quant à geneviève elle affirme avoir
réalisé un rêve en se lançant à faire
même s'il se dit encore nostalgique de
son ancien métier enseigne me manque
énormément
c'est la pédagogue mois seulement mais
puisque je faisais à la fin de ma chère
ici jean philippe robillard radio canada
salaberry-de-valleyfield
[Musique]